[Musica]
anzitutto buona sera partiremo con
qualcosa di diverso
tre sono i concetti che ho dovuto a
ridefinire durante la mia crescita che
hanno dato forma al mio pensiero che
hanno cambiato quello che chiamavo
ordinario e ciò che chiamiamo
straordinario vedete questi tre concetti
secondo me sono molto importanti e oggi
partiranno per un viaggio per esplorarli
sono tre tappe i confini gli errori e il
tempo ricordate queste tre parole ci
serviranno confini errori e tempo io
sono mattia strocchi ho 19 anni e tre
anni fa ho iniziato un progetto che ha
cambiato il mio modo di vedere le cose
non è solo una questione di vedere le
cose secondo me e per questo motivo
vorrei spiegarvi vorrei oggi presentarvi
il mio progetto
tutto è partito da una domanda avete
presente quando i professori dicono suo
figlio signora ha delle grandi
potenzialità ma dovrebbe imparare a
concentrarsi di più sullo studio
purtroppo io una domanda che ho sentito
spesso e vorrei con voi però chiederla
quanti di voi hanno mai sentito questa
questa cosa suo figlio signora ha delle
grandi potenzialità ma sono inespresse
non riesce a studiare
io devo oltre alla mano l'ho sentita
spero di non essere lui ho visto
qualcuno che alzato la mano e questa
domanda è stato uno dei miei man focus
perché purtroppo succedeva spesso
tornava a casa mia madre è purtroppo mi
diceva queste parole già sentite
ripetere mille volte non sapevo come
affrontarle c'è stato un momento della
mia vita in cui avevo molte domande e
poche risposte
penso che tutti gli adolescenti
l'abbiano passato abbastanza difficile
perché non sai come tiratene fuori
quello che ho fatto è stato formi delle
altre domande a mia volta e aveva una
grande passione per l'elettronica
volevo capire
come sarebbe andata a finire
l'interfaccia uomo macchina dove saremo
arrivati
oggi prevalentemente il gioco si si
svolge su touch screen e pulsanti no
pensateci tutti i dispositivi che
abbiamo sono fondamentalmente
controllati o da uno da un touchscreen o
dei pulsanti ma non sempre sono efficaci
come metodi questi per persone che hanno
problemi di tipo motorio o disabilità
non si possono utilizzare gli stessi
sistemi perché purtroppo non li vendo
non li rendono partecipi partendo da
questo problema
volevo trovare una soluzione
e questa cosa è saltata fuori con
l'elettromiografia elettromiografia un
esame di tipo medico che esiste da tempo
serve per analizzare l'attività
muscolare e allo stesso tempo darci
informazioni sullo stato di salute del
muscolo le protesi più avanzate riescono
addirittura attraverso
l'elettromiografia ad essere controllate
ciò significa in buona sostanza che io
collego questi elettrodi al mio muscolo
è semplicemente muovendo il mio corpo
posso controllare qualcosa allora di
solito le persone mi chiedono scusa tu
stai dicendo che io muovo il mio corpo e
possa spostare qualcosa che faccio così
con il braccio esposto dal tavolino
no quella è telecinesi è una cosa un
attimo diversa esiste nei cartoni in
star trek in tante serie però non è
quello di cui sto parlando
una volta è successo anche di meglio
però arrivata una persona mi ha chiesto
dai ho capito che cosa vuoi fare
scusa ma tu hai diventare uno jedi
avete presente no ai jedi con le loro
fantastiche mosse che riescono a
spostare persone e alzarle per aria
questo simpatico maestro yoda
ma no a un obiettivo migliore stai
sereno proviamo a fare qualcosa di utile
per le persone
così è saltato fuori orion corian è un
esoscheletro riabilitativo l'idea
fondamentale è quella di portare la
riabilitazione a casa delle persone e
allo stesso tempo farlo in modo attivo
attivo significa che il segnale
muscolare è utilizzato sia per dare
informazioni sullo stato di salute del
muscolo che allo stesso tempo per
migliorare la velocità con cui si fa
riabilitazione
il tutor e modifica il suo comportamento
proprio sulla base di questo segnale è
un'idea semplice ma potevo aiutare molte
persone a fare riabilitazione
il prototipo è ancora in fase di
sviluppo
però quello che volevo dimostrare che
sentivo il mio vero obiettivo come
studente era riuscire a far capire che
queste tecnologie sono accessibili a
tutti
ci sono sistemi ad esoscheletro che oggi
costano fino a 400mila euro 400mila euro
e sono tuttora ricerca sono cifre
assolutamente inaffrontabili a volte
anche per centri di ricerca di oggi con
me non ho le sue scheletro ma ho portato
un'altra cosa che parla proprio di
questa innovazione che parte dal basso
parte dal presupposto che non tutti
abbiano molti soldi per poter sviluppare
della tecnologia nascosta qui sotto è
una mano robotica e posso assicurarvi
che si muove quello che volevo
dimostrare è che questo sistema qui
assegnarsi di movimento uno per ogni
dito si farà mosse stupide st scorcio
costa e a sei assi di movimento e
sensore di pressione sulle dita
quindi un giorno si potrebbe anche
ripristinare il tatto alle persone e
ancora come dire molto molto da
ingegnerizzare ma la dimostrazione di
questa tecnologia è che è completamente
accessibile
questo è un progetto open source vuol
dire che ognuno di voi qui in sala lo
può scaricare e può fare di questa cosa
qui qualcosa migliore può aggiornare il
progetto può modificarlo o scaricarlo e
stamparlo a casa sua con la stampante 3d
e voi potrete obiettarmi io non ho una
stampante di va bene allora va in un fab
lab e tela stampano loro sapete qual è
la caratteristica più importante di
quell'oggetto costa 40 euro
tutto intero questa volante euro e
protesi attuali di quel livello costa
intorno ai 40 mila euro
facciamo una volta di conti
il rapporto di acquista mille a 1 1000 a
1 non so se ci rendiamo conto della
grandezza
ora proviamo a spiegarlo meglio qui di
fronte abbiamo sedici colonne ci sono 16
sedie in questa riga e le righe di
questa e le colonne di questa le righe
di questa sala che si sono le colonne
della vostro fare sono quindici
se facciamo 15 per 19 quanto ci viene
viene 285 mille meno 285 fa 715 vuol
dire che ogni persona qui tra voi
potrebbe avere una di queste è
rimarrebbero altri 715 protesi
guardatevi un po provate a capire quanti
siete
sono serie provate a guardarvi e pensate
che altre 715 protesi si potrebbero
avere con in corso di una singola
disponibile sul mercato adesso sembra
potente la cosa no
ma andiamo avanti io oggi volevo
parlarvi di qualcosa in più che un
semplice progetto che è quello che è
stato il mio drive fin dall'inizio
c'è una frase di antoine de saint
exupery l'autore del piccolo principe
che trovo abbia molto significato e dice
se vuoi costruì una barca non radunare
uomini per tagliare legna dividere i
compiti e impartire ordini ma insegna
loro la nostalgia per il mare roster
infinito che cosa significa significa
che le conoscenze nella vita quella
analitica e sono molto importanti ma ciò
che più importante avere una mente
aperta e disposta a scoprire per questo
vi racconta tre storie
la prima parla di luca e chiara sono due
ragazzi che ho conosciuto a maker ferro
durante uno dei miei viaggi per per la
mano robotica e dello scheletro chiaro è
costretto in sedia a rotelle dalla
nascita purtroppo è nata prematura
luca invece aveva una grande fratello e
aveva una grande passione per la
per l'ingegneria quello che voleva fare
era unire la sua passione e fare
qualcosa di più ha capito che il suo
progetto di esoscheletro poteva
diventare un utilità sociale poteva
riuscire a coinvolgere le persone
diventare qualcosa di più grande fare
inclusive innovation che fare con le
persone non per le persone
c'è molta differenza ricordate da fare
con le persone non per le persone ma
oltre a questo c'è anche un'altra storia
questa storia è ben diversa e parla di
ostacoli
prendi poi quest'uomo è stato un
insegnante alla carnegie mellon
university insegnante di informatica ha
46 anni gli è stato diagnosticato un
cancro al pancreas
quando gli è stato trovato purtroppo non
c'era molta speranza perché alla visita
dopo quella di controllo gli hanno detto
randy ai 9 metastasi e quando ai 9
metastasi ti rimangono pochi mesi da
vivere non c'è più non puoi più
combattere contro il cancro
lui aveva un problema abbastanza grosso
perché aveva dei figli di 53 e un anno
come fare trasmettere dei valori morali
ha figli così piccoli che non si
ricorderanno forse neanche di te ha
fatto qualcosa di grandioso ha scritto
un libro chiamato l'ultima lezione in
questo libro ci insegna che i sogni che
vogliamo raggiungere da piccoli quelli
da vostra infanzia in realtà si
raggiungono se ci comportiamo nel modo
giusto e penso che sia una cosa
assolutamente incredibile ma parla anche
di un'altra cosa che è molto sottile
nel suo libro di questa cosa qui i muri
esistono per una ragione non certo per
allontanarci ma per darci la possibilità
di dimostrare quanto davvero desideriamo
qualcosa questo è qualcosa di nuovo
incredibile perché se ci pensate
tutti noi ci troviamo ad affrontare
ostacoli nella vita
a volte ci demoralizziamo pensavo di non
potercela fare
ed è così capita a tutti non ci sono
debolezze nella mettere questo però
dobbiamo percepire gli ostacoli come
qualcosa che ci serve per misurarci per
migliorare per andare oltre
ora un'altra domanda
cambiamo discorso qualcuno di voi ha mai
giocato a pallavolo
ho tante persone qual è la fra la parola
scusatemi che assolutamente vietata
nella pallavolo
qualcuno lo sa urlatelo mi sembra che
qualcuno abbia detto è tua tua tu non
puoi dire tua nella pallavolo ha
significato questa cosa no
penso che sia un atto di
responsabilizzazione estrema e potente
la cosa tua significa che in buona
sostanza tidei prendere le tue
responsabilità se è l'unico padrone del
tuo destino
provate a mettermi in questa situazione
siete al match point di una partita è
l'ultimo punto quello che decreta la
vittoria
siete una squadra però l'ultima palla la
prendo una persona e quella persona fa
la differenza tra la vittoria e aver
perso si gioca sempre in squadra nella
vita che lo vogliamo che non lo vogliamo
però le nostre responsabilità quelle del
singolo fanno la differenza tra vittorio
la perdita è a questo punto voi vi
starete chiedendo scusa ma queste storie
di cosa stiamo parlando perché abbiamo
parlato di tre storie diverse e si
bellissime forma di cosa stiamo parlando
avete presente di nuovo la frase di
antoine de saint exupéry quella del
piccolo principe
noi non vogliamo prendere della legna
per questo di una barca
noi vogliamo trovare la nostalgia per il
mare vasto e l'infinito e queste sono le
nostre tre storie perché pensateci
all'inizio vi ho fatto una promessa che
era quella di avere tre tappe nel nostro
viaggio i confini gli errori e il tempo
e allora così partiamo dalla prima tappa
il tempo randy pausch un uomo che è
riuscito a creare tempo illimitato
partendo da un tempo finito ha preso un
tempo finito e pensateci ha creato un
ricordo che durerà per sempre ha scritto
un libro è riuscito a dare un
insegnamento morale ai suoi figli a
vivere con la sua famiglia
lui è simbolo del tempo ci sono i
confini poi i confini sono luca è chiara
no non sono i confini sono simbolo dell
inesistenza dei confini look e chiara
perché hanno fatto molto di più sono
riusciti a ridefinire i confini della
disabilità e diffondere la loro idea nel
mondo dei maker vanno condividere con
tutti
questo significa che ogni persona nel
mondo può prendere l'esempio di look e
chiara e fare quello che hanno fatto e
partire di lì per continuare e
sviluppare il progetto
poi abbiamo l'ultimo dei nostri punti
che il concetto di errore rimane solo
una cosa avrete capito qual è l'errore
quel dì la tua
perché non c'è nessuna nostra
responsabilità che possa essere delegato
a qualcun altro
gli errori si commettono nella vita ne
abbiamo commessi tutti io per primo
però gli errori ci servono per fare
meglio e non dovremmo mai dimenticarlo
perché questi errori la capacità di fare
errori ci porta a cose più grandi a cosa
enormi che non ci aspetteremmo neanche e
con questi tre concetti
vorrei chiudere la mia talk allo stesso
modo in cui siamo partiti perché dopo
ogni confine che superiamo c'è un nuovo
inizio
dimenticato i confini esplorate
l'astratto grazie